hello and welcome im sue me so Miss
Conda and you're watching world stories
your international reporters magazine
this week we'll look at new ways to
bring snail mail into the 21st century
we meet two young Croatian designers who
are thinking big and swimming in midair
it's possible all those stories and more
coming up but first in May 2013 samina
baig became the first Pakistani woman to
climb Mount Everest it was a remarkable
accomplishment for many reasons for one
Mount Everest is the highest peak in the
world and climbers have to overcome
incredible odds to get to the top but
Samina also comes from a society where
women are not encouraged to reach so
high still it's nothing new for the 22
year old just three years before she
became the first person ever to scale
Chechens are a towering peak in pakistan
jawad jury from black box sounds caught
up with Samina to talk about that brave
feet
oh man I'm climbing a big hair or my
name is Serena big and I come from a
small village called shimshon in the
Hunza Valley it's located 3,300 meters
above sea level life here is very harsh
and tough halfway up in Hawaii along our
village is surrounded by mountains on
all sides living here I became friends
with the mountains and have wanted to be
a professional climber ever since I was
a child which Munson was a short up this
guy fishing though their decision was
your pardon but it's always been her
passion hi mom she used to say she
wanted to climb ice covered mountains
not regular ones on the rez art yeah it
took us three days to reach the base
camp on shush kansaw further up still we
set up a high camp
I on our way to the summit around 20
meters up from the high camp my feet
went numb to me talk about 20 metres de
about major volunteer was inaugurated
watch other at around five thousand
eight hundred meters her feet went numb
and she couldn't walk
with a Morgul embezzling I thought I
wouldn't be able to make it because I
couldn't feel my legs but with God's
help we were able to make it to the
summit I'm gonna go yes Emma
semak bear whines naked by a feeling I
had after reaching the top of the
mountain was unforgettable and
unbelievable when I waved the flag of
Pakistan on the summit I cried it was a
very joyous moment for me it's something
I'll never forget ergo MacCabe be nimble
tactic the Pakistani the first time she
arrived was a very great moment for her
aglet viaje if a girl can scale a
mountain then there's nothing she can't
do no matter what her professional all
it takes is hard work passion commitment
and encouragement engagement was early
very courageous indeed now privacy
versus security how do you balance the
two that's a question that's on a lot of
people's minds right now revelations
that the US government has been spying
on the calls and emails of millions
around the world has sparked
international outrage but plenty of
people say they're willing to give up
their privacy in exchange for safety or
even convenience that takes us to our
next story to a company in the US that's
offering to save you precious time by
digitizing all your snail mail great
idea as long as you don't mind someone
reading your personal letters Christina
elsasser reports for centuries Americans
have collected their post from male
boxes like this but they soon could be a
thing of the past a new company called
outbox wants to turn people snail mail
into email for less than four euros a
month one of its unposted as they're
called will drop by your house to pick
up your mail before you even get to see
it the letters are then whisked off to a
processing center where they're opened
scant and stored online
people are really intrigued by the idea
of having access to their mail digitally
it's a whole new line of communication
you know that they're interested in
exploring and there's definitely a lot
of a lot of hype once uploaded to the
net the snail mail can be read via a
home computer tablet pc or smartphone
anytime anywhere businessman francis
pedraza decided to give it a go all i
had to do was take a photo of my mail
key and they were able to pick it out
for me and i got a notification shortly
after saying my you could check your
mail and all the junk mail that i
received was right there and I could hit
the unsubscribe button and it'll never
get printed again and I can put the rest
of it into folders the the stuff I do
actually physically want I can ask for
and they'll make sure that I get it in
my mailbox see that out bulk seems to
take the hassle out of traditional mail
postman had been doing their rounds in
the US since 1775 when the united states
postal service was established its goal
was to provide an efficient safe and
affordable mail service
it now delivers mail to more than 150
million households across America but
some say it's not keeping up with the x
box founder will davis is one of them
he's determined to bring traditional
snail mail bang up to date it's not that
people don't like Mayo is so they don't
like the negative attributes of mail
that don't line up with their lives and
so the fact that they can't view it from
anywhere or they can unsubscribe from
postal mail or they can't respond to
things on their phone they have to
respond in physical form what we try to
do is take out all the negative aspects
of postal mail and bring it into the
21st century in a way that you and me
live our daily lives the founders of
outbox a snail mail still has a future
despite the increasing popularity of
email if their new concept proves a hit
they plan to send out unposted to all
American neighborhoods well on July
first Croatia will become the 28th
member of the European Union a move that
will bring big changes to the small
Balkan country opening new markets and
creating exciting opportunities in our
next story Marina shoe burrito from HRT
introduces us to an association that's
looking to take advantage of that by
working to introduce the best of
Croatian art fashion and design onto the
global stage here's more in recent years
Croatian designers have made a name for
themselves both at home and abroad but
getting that big break can often prove
difficult that's why designers Eva tujhe
and romina uncheck wanted to find a way
of helping designers break through onto
the international scene they came up
with all phases an association that
helps promote promising young people and
big-name designers from every medium
they hope Croatia's membership in the EU
well
then tap into new markets opium oh
really we've assembled a big team from
design dance and music so we're not
limited to fashion we're aiming to take
on the European market when we join the
EU were planning to exhibit at fairs and
established fashion events all over
Europe nochum or the manifest at SEMA 30
year old jewelry designer on avantage
says joining all phases has helped her
hand painted medallions reach a wider
clientele you're not bad masti one of
the association's advantages is that we
can go to fairs together they're usually
expensive but we can share the
registration fee socialize exchange
ideas and you always learn or find out
something new sizing them the designers
hope the quality of their products will
allow them to hold their own against the
mass-produced designs that currently
dominate the market they say all phases
is vital in helping them spread the word
I mean as I said I would die soon I'm
really glad there's an initiative like
this and that all faces is promoting
Croatian design and Croatian artists I
think it's necessary in this time of
crisis and recession for people to join
forces and create a common brand to
promote local work outside of Croatia
vans mi marido de las casas to Roddy I
wanted a team that's professional whose
work shows maturity and experience and
that has lots of enthusiasm and optimism
we've picked a good time to do it EU
membership will open the borders and
make it easy to export our product that
was always our biggest problems and I'm
a theme of belong neither to problem but
all faces also aims to bring foreign
customers to Croatia just before the
holiday season it said about opening a
chain of stores along the adriatic coast
that stock only croatian products por
ser Donnel nashik bracket up one of our
projects involves cooperating with
hotels so it means working in the
tourist industry he's the samel credit
at school with more holidaymakers coming
to croatia our local designers won't
have to travel and take their work
abroad
they can stay right here in Croatia but
overstock bottom first will open
exhibitions and sales outlets to
showcase our artists work the first
shops will be in pula and rovenia and
were also planning to open shops in
rijeka and makarska eplan adamo da cui
Marcus school all phases hopes to
conquer Europe with designs made in
Croatia and we wish them all the best
Shanghai is China's biggest city an
incredible mix of traditional and modern
of West and East there's plenty to see
and do there but when summer hits
reporter Leo shoe jia from her partner
station ICS has a very special tip for
you go swimming as she shows us locals
and visitors love to take a dip during
the hottest months and they do so in
style we introduce you to some of
shanghai's most daring swimming pools
from dizzying heights two bright lights
take a look it might look like any other
pool at first glance but take a dip at
the Holiday Inn in Shanghai for a
one-of-a-kind swimming experience I've
been to many swimming pools in the city
and this one yes I know what you're
gonna say the view it's not that good
but if you look down you actually can
see the reception area of the hotel well
if anybody working now am I gonna say
hello the pools depend has a view
straight down 24 stories all that
separates swimmers from the street below
is a pain of toughened glass if you
haven't got a head for Heights you might
want to stay in the shallow end oh i
should say this is probably the first
swimming pool in this type in San hi
this pool is nine especially in Shanghai
this is probably a world first to have a
cantilever swimming pool and so by that
we mean a pool that hangs outside the
building and with a glass base so you
can look down at the ground
so it really is quite a unique
experience and it's very popular with
both hotel guests and local businesses
yeah that's interesting if you have any
guests to come into the hotel and then
look up maybe you they will find a
friend Ashley swimming in your swimming
pool we have people who will run
downstairs go outside and take photos of
their partner in the pool up 24 floors
above is just great and we last week we
even had somebody tried to do handstands
on the glass space which is quite unique
experience how do you keep the guests
saved when they swim I mean it's a bit
scary when they swim isn't it you're
twenty four floors up and you don't want
any problems so in terms of the size of
the pool and the water volume in the
pool has been carefully measured to
ensure it's safe and of course the glass
is reinforced and how steel within so
that there's no risk at all to anybody
using it the pool is 30 metres long and
six metres wide constructing the
death-defying deep end was a major
challenge the hotel consulted various
architects and even aerospace engineers
to make sure it would be safe to take a
dip swimmers here think it was well
worth the effort well it's scary where I
am what's it like actually standing in
the water oh it's exciting I've never
experienced anything like it if you're
looking for a pool with a view this
might just be the one for you they don't
come more scenic than this one if that
isn't your cup of tea you might want to
check out another pool that's making
waves in Shanghai this pool belongs to
the undoes hotel measuring 15 meters
long and 5 meters wide the pool is lit
entirely by blue LED lights to help
swimmers relax and unwind
instead of a glass-bottom this one has
see-through sides it's proving a big hit
with the guests can you tell me LED
swimming for a hotel the use of LED
light is actually quite consistent
throughout the hotel and here using LED
particularly a blue color is to give a
very tranquil feeling to the swimming
pool most important of all this is not
just a normal swimming pool surrounded
by concrete it's a acrylic slabs so this
is like a transparent pull like an
aquarium and how opens can guess using
this swimming pool our in house guests
of course we welcome them here from six
o'clock in the morning to 11 p.m. in the
evening for our fitness studios we
welcome outside guests who are not
staying in the hotel to come in here to
use the facility based on a membership
that they acquire from the hotel so when
you are a member of the fitness studio
you can also use the pool
the pool features a special spillover
design which allows excess water to run
over the sides and down the transparent
tiles it's known in the trade as an
infinity pool
well hope you've enjoyed would we find
in shanghai's five-star hotels now it's
my time to jump into the pool if you
like water and are looking for a place
to party then check out the rooftop
swimming pool at the Grand gateway when
we talk about summer swimming pools we
cannot forget this summer pool parties
the left join them go aside from water
there's also plenty of music food and
alcohol for partygoers to enjoy these
revelers can't get enough of it I think
I need to get in before you remaining a
reliance super party everything is great
now that's a wrap up of some of the
coolest swimming experiences that
Shanghai has to offer so go find that
bathing suit get out there and get wet
looks like fun and finally to a remote
mountain village called quit salon
that's been dubbed a magic town part of
the magic is the atmosphere the quaint
buildings and cobbled streets the
markets the waterfalls and the rich
indigenous culture but there's another
element a unique ancestral dance that
involves a lot of skill and even more
courage Miguel Ceballos from Mexico's
Puebla TV shows us more perched high up
on the slopes of Mexico Sierra Norte is
quite salon del progreso the town and
its neighboring settlements are home to
thriving indigenous communities their
laws Quarren parsippany was in the last
census we counted over 47,000 people in
the municipality of them seventy-three
percent were of indigenous origin
they're spread throughout more than 160
towns and villages in the area ligament
despite the passage of time people here
have managed to preserve many of their
ancient customs and ceremonies nowadays
the town combines the best of tradition
and modernity among quits islands many
customs is the dance of the Flyers this
ancient ritual pays homage to the gods
and is believed to help provide the town
with a bountiful harvest every year to
take part in or even witness this dance
opens the door to the spiritual world of
the indigenous noir population
these dancers are called voladores which
means the Flyers they perform a brief
dance before climbing a tree trunk to a
height of nearly 30 meters once at the
top a priest turns to the north east
south and west praying to nature the
universe and the gods now the flight can
begin the four Flyers launch themselves
from the top of the pole and begin
circling it upside down
traga dan says it's a great honor to
take part in the ceremony yeah well as
he is it isn't that easy and there's
always a risk of something going wrong
we offer ourselves as sacrifices but
we're always afraid having said that
we're very experienced and focused and
we believe in what we're doing for me it
has a personal meeting it's the
fulfillment of my life it's something
has always existed well it's an inner
calling and I believe in what my dance
symbolizes that is a fertility and its
significance I think if girls get you
know part of me the ritual actually
begins with the selection of the pole
the dancers go out in search of a tall
and sturdy tree in the nearby forests
que nosotros hacemos des vestidos de
blanco dress all in white that's how we
present ourselves to nature when we take
the tree from her in return we give her
incense cigars holy water spirits
flowers and fruits de is what in the--
we go to the tree and bring these gifts
one after another gracias a los por ESO
el sabado todo lo que seamos we cross
ourselves and prostrate ourselves when
we hand them over then we cut the tree
down everyone after the tree is felled
it's taken to the village and set up in
the main square offerings are then made
to the gods among them a live turkey if
your holiday we will we take this live
turkey and put it into the hole that
anchors the tree so the trunk actually
kills it doses give us a that grants us
protection no para nosotros the
tradition has been handed down from
father to son through the ages surviving
even mexico's colonial era the dance is
now gaining in popularity although
partly for its value is
practical the town of Quetta and El
Progreso itself still has many
colonial-era buildings along with a
network of cobbled streets many
residents go about in indigenous dress
giving visitors a sense of what life was
like here centuries ago quit salon is
home to the only statue of the Virgin
Mary in the whole of Mexico that wears
indigenous dress she's worn this white
robe embroidered with simple but
colorful designs for seven years now a
solicitor we asked the Vatican for
permission to dress the Virgin Mary in
this costume typical of kawat salon we
sent in photos and fortunately they
agreed las fotos de como el traje tipico
is we identify ourselves with her we say
this is our Blessed Virgin our mother of
God and she dresses like we do for
people here the statue is also a way to
teach younger generations about their
heritage school is also instrumental
lessons here are taught in two languages
in Spanish and Nava to the ancient
language of the Aztecs quit salon del
progreso one small but fascinating patch
in Mexico's multicultural quilt of more
than 60 indigenous groups
and that's all for this week's edition
of worlds stories for all of us here in
our partner stations and contributing
reporters around the world thanks for
watching don't forget you can watch the
show again at our website that's DWD
forward slash world stories before we go
here are some images that caught our eye
this week in our pics of the world see
you next time for more world stories